cómo es que hemos vaciado de contenido
del noviazgo el noviazgo hoy como
relación ha fracasado ha fracasado
porque los que se casan se divorcian y
los que terminan terminan mal el buen
noviazgo es la relación que mira al
matrimonio construye familias fuertes
garantiza hijos felices edifica
sociedades plenas soy antonella fermín
esposa madre orgullosa venezolana
mexicana de corazón profesora en esta
universidad y vengo a decirle como en
mis años de experiencia de estudios he
visto como hemos convertido al noviazgo
hoy en fuente de infelicidad han
escuchado expresiones como nos gustamos
porque no andamos no es lo que sigue o
los ex friends que le gustan mejor
decirse en novio o novia a los amigos
con derechos suelen tomar el título
también
la que se acerca a los 30 o pasa de
ellos y antes de conquistar la soltería
a los 35 te presenta su peor en nada y
como de esos tantísimos ejemplos que
vemos alrededor estas expresiones no
solamente se escuchan en méxico también
se escuchan en venezuela y en muchísimos
países nos imponemos en relaciones de
noviazgo que no van a ser exitosas
estamos en relaciones que no nos llevan
a amar
a construir el amor verdadero que tanto
anhelamos
esto no solamente lo he visto en los
alumnos en los jóvenes en mi círculo
amigos en consultoría alguna vez sino
que también lo viví en carne propia
tenía yo unos 19 años pocos meses antes
de cumplir 20 cuando me encontraba en la
situación de no haber tenido jamás un
novia
se podrán imaginar que la presión social
y las ganas de acabar con esto me durará
un poco de esa edad
así que poco poco antes de cumplir los
20 me convertí en novia de alguien por
primera vez el 17 de diciembre del 2009
se podrán imaginar que mi euforia no era
normal o sea ya tenía mi primer novio
recuerdo haber preguntado a mi papá a
quien siempre le tenido muchísima
confianza
oye para este a este novio mío qué
calificación le pones tú del 1 al 10
y mi papá con esa tranquilidad que le
caracteriza esa contundencia que tiene
al dar la respuesta y esa sabiduría con
que esas respuestas están siempre
cargadas me dijo antonella hija bella
siendo muy generosos le doy un 5
hasta entonces siempre había pensado que
mi papá era muy objetivo pero recuerdo
ese día que lo baje del pedestal lo
tache de su objetivo sin saber que mi
papá me estaba dando un presagio del
futuro cuando tenía 19 años y me
convertí en obra de alguien por primera
vez no sabía lo que quería es más no
tenía una idea realmente clara de lo que
era el noviazgo eso le pasa a los novios
de hoy los novios de hoy realmente no se
conocen a sí mismos no conocen a la
persona del otro no son capaces de tener
una comunicación real y auténtica y
cuando tienen la comunicación es
superficial los novios de hoy no saben
lo que es el matrimonio y mucho menos lo
que es una familia el noviazgo de hoy es
el control excesivo la neurosis del
inseguro dice un profesor de esta
universidad que los novios de hoy creen
que piensan lo mismo cuando realmente
solo sienten lo mismo piensan que están
unidos cuando realmente solo están
juntos
piensan que se aman cuando realmente
solo se desea
esto se verifica cuando oyen méxico
según datos del inegi en 2017 dos de
cada tres niños nacen fuera del
matrimonio eso quiere decir que estos
dos niños no tendrán ejemplo de amor
verdadero en el mejor de los casos
tendrán dos casas dos cuartos dos camas
dos horarios dos rutinas el corazón
dividido entre la casa de mamá y la casa
de papá y digo en el mejor de los casos
porque en la mayoría de los casos uno de
los dos padres se desvincula del hijo
el inegi nos dice hoy también que dos de
cada cinco matrimonios realizados en los
últimos quince años se habrían
divorciado antes de cumplir cinco años
de casado eso quiere decir que si en
esta sala son los 300 personas poco
menos de la mitad vamos a durar menos de
5 años de casados
vivimos en una sociedad de personas
rotas de personas en donde su rostro no
se habla de sonrisas porque no han
sabido conquistar y conservar ese amor
verdadero así estaba yo rota cuando
después de dos años y diez meses de
relación me di cuenta que ese novio no
me convenía que si seguía con él no iba
a ser feliz
fue muy difícil muy duro tomar la
decisión de terminar pero la ambición en
mi corazón de poder encontrar realmente
ese amor verdadero me dio la fuerza para
decirle un día hasta aquí recuerdo de
esa conversación muy bien casi casi como
si fuera ayer
recuerdo que estaba yo he hecho un mar
de lágrimas cuando le prometí una
promesa que realmente me hacía más a mí
le dije fulano
quiero que sepas
que mi próximo novio será con seguridad
mi esposo y padre mi hijo
me casé con esa promesa así que me
dediqué a investigar a grado tal que me
inscribí en una maestría de matrimonio y
familia
pues yo tenía que dar con el fondo del
asunto yo tenía que asegurar que en mi
siguiente novio fuera mi esposo y padre
de mis hijos
y después de tanto de tanto estudiar y
salir y ver a la gente y verme a mí
concluir que el noviazgo es la relación
en donde un varón y una mujer se conoce
conocen sus valores sus virtudes sus
talentos sus criterios sus prioridades
sus defectos todo aquello que involucre
la decisión de ver si la otra persona
puede ser con quien yo puedo construir
un recorrido biográfico feliz si puede
ser con esa persona con quien yo puedo
hacer un matrimonio fecundo y
trascendente en donde no solamente se
conquiste la felicidad de los
participantes sino también en donde se
pueda garantizar seres hijos felices que
edifiquen esa sociedad plena que tanto
anhelamos
en el noviazgo también la persona tiene
que conocer y discernir si la otra
persona es con quién puede realmente
amar y construir ese amor se tiene que
dar cuenta si tiene la capacidad de
querer querer al otro por el resto de su
vida no solamente abrazando con fervor
sus virtudes y sus talentos sino
abrazando con aún mayor fervor sus
defectos porque nos casamos con alguien
imperfecto cuando me doy cuenta que
tengo esa capacidad de entonces me doy
cuenta que me he convertido en amante
porque el amante dentro del noviazgo es
quien busca su felicidad personal a
través de conquistar la felicidad
personal del ser amado descubrí también
que el buen noviazgo tiene siempre y
solo dos finales felices siempre y solo
dos finales felices
el primero es casarse con aquella
persona y el tiempo lo corroborará podré
construir un recorrido biográfico feliz
un matrimonio fecundo y trascendente y
el segundo final feliz es terminar y
terminar bien sin rencores sin heridas
sin traumas para que esos dos individuos
puedan volar y seriedad' el mundo para
conocer con quien sí podrán construir
ese amor verdadero y esto no es justo
pía ni es película esto es realidad lo
vemos en matrimonios de la historia como
el matrimonio de la reina victoria y el
príncipe alberto nueve hijos veinte años
de casados después de la partida del
príncipe alberto la reina victoria'
vistió de luto el resto de su vida para
gritarle al mundo que su amor seguía
vivo ana magdalena will que la esposa de
johann sebastian bach decía para poder
comprender a sebastián hay que amarlo y
porque yo lo amado toda mi vida lo he
comprendido
nos damos cuenta entonces que el amor
verdadero es posible y para conquistarlo
hay que tener buen noviazgo
yo he concluido que para tener ese buen
noviazgo hay que tener tres premisas
claras la primera es que el buen
noviazgo mira un fin fecundo y
trascendente el matrimonio es decir el
noviazgo no es un medio los novios
eternos no son novios porque el noviazgo
tiene un fin el matrimonio
la segunda premisa es que en el buen
noviazgo sus participantes son personas
maduras aquellas que tienen la capacidad
para discernir si el otro es con quien
podrán realmente formar ese matrimonio
fecundo y trascendente y la tercera
premisa es que en el buen noviazgo se ha
de tener un diálogo de conocimiento y
convivencia en donde los enamorados se
convierten en amantes y no me refiero de
los amantes que se meten a la cama me
refiero a los amantes que aman
aristóteles decía el que ama busca el
bien del otro por el otro el amante se
gasta la vida en la felicidad del ser
amado querrán saber entonces y cumplí mi
promesa
pues debo decirle que el 14 de octubre
del 2016 mismo día que en el 2012 yo
terminé con mi primer novio
mi cesar mi segundo novio hoy mi esposo
y padre de mi hijo me pidió matrimonio
queremos ser felices pero olvidamos el
ámbito de la vida más importante el amor
queremos que nuestra vida hable de
sonrisas pero olvidamos el ámbito más
importante de la vida que es el amor
atrévanse de amar sean decididos
reflexiones no se dejen llevar
construyamos familias fuertes
garanticemos hijos felices edifiquemos
sociedades plenas tengamos buenos
noviazgos
[Aplausos]